there's this really big story going
around claiming that the bite
administration was funding the
distribution of crack pipes
snopes ran one of the greatest fact
checks i've ever seen where they said
it's mostly false he's also giving out
syringes and i'm like i don't know how
that makes it false but i guess
in some strange technicality you can
argue the story is not true because
there's more to the story well now the
white house is disputing it claiming
their safe their safe smoking kit is
actually not it doesn't include crack
pipes but if you actually look up
standard safe smoking kits given out for
drug intervention it includes meth pipes
and crack pipes so i don't understand
why theirs wouldn't have that kind of
think they're lying but joe biden's
approval rating is in the gutter it's
lower than trump's was at the same time
in aggregate so this is all the polls
combined i think it's fair to say that
joe biden has done a miserable job we
got a lot to talk about and joining us
to talk about that and so much more are
two incredible members of congress we
have thomas massey and marjorie taylor
green uh thomas do you want to start by
introducing yourself um i'm from
kentucky i'm a high-tech redneck grew up
as a hillbilly still a hillbilly went to
mit
live off the grid
of for some crazy reason i ran for
congress and here i am
mit hillbilly sounds like a good sitcom
to be honest
yeah
you could come to our house and watch it
because my wife is an mit hillbilly and
we have a son who's an mit hillbilly wow
cool cool i'm really excited to hear
about the klux capacitor your chicken
technology latest invention on the farm
sweet i'm a big chicken fan so we'll
talk about that marjorie you want to
introduce yourself yes um my name is
marjorie taylor green from georgia um
freshman member of congress and i don't
i'm i'm i'm kind of like you thomas i'm
i question myself sometimes like what
made me run but i think uh america's
worth saving and happy to be here with
my good friend thomas massey and join
you all so this is gonna be a lot of fun
excited to have you both and we also
have seamus coughlin of freedom tunes
yes jameis coughlin freedom tunes it's a
political cartooning channel where i
upload new animations every thursday we
have one coming out tomorrow about the
feds that i think is pretty funny we're
very happy with it and i also released
one two days ago about joe rogan and
fauci tim was in it yeah what's up
everybody the voice of dr fountain and
it was it was really well done great
thank you and welcome hey ian crossland
happy to be here guys looking forward to
talking tech and politics see you soon i
am also here pushing all the buttons in
the corner wish me luck tonight we have
a lot of people here tonight but we'll
make it work we will before we get
started though we have a really awesome
sponsor i'm proud to shout out virtual
shield go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
50 off of virtual shields product for
life a vpn gives you a basic layer of
security and i've i'm really excited to
be shouting them out for one they've
been a sponsor of r since the very
beginning so i'm grateful
but you look at what's going on the
january 6 committee you look at how
they're getting phone records from
private citizens without any speed bumps
they go to these companies and say give
us the records and the company say you
got it there's supposed to be a fourth
amendment well you got to take privacy
into your own hands and make sure you're
doing what you can to ensure that
privacy in a virtual private network can
help you do that virtual shield says
their vpn service is compatible with all
devices it allows you to browse the web
safely securely and anonymously using
their global network of servers and
private ips it lets you browse the web
completely anonymously so the big name
in internet service providers and other
third parties will not be able to
monitor your internet activity and
browsing history
and you can enjoy fast reliable and
secure on their always available network
network you get 30 days free it works on
mac windows iphone ipad android and
chrome it does all the work for you your
entire connection becomes secure private
and encrypted i tell you look no
security is ever perfect but this is a
basic layer of defense that you can get
for your internet and it will help stop
prying eyes government actors hackers
and other nefarious types from stealing
your data so go to surfing
internetsafe.com get virtual shield
today thank you very much virtual shield
and don't forget to go to timcast.com if
you want to directly support our
journalists and the work we do we're
gonna have a members only podcast up
around 11 p.m tonight with all of our
guests it's going to be a whole lot of
fun you don't want to miss it so again
timcast.com but don't forget smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends and now
let's get into that big story that's
been going around that everybody can't
stop talking about newsweek reports
white house says crack pipes never
included in safe smoking kits i think
this story is particularly interesting
to me because i can understand wanting
to
intervene to help people who are
addicted to drugs to lower drug
infection rates to get them into safe
environments and help them get off drugs
the problem i have with this story is
that for one i think the white house is
lying about not including crack pipes
and i think giving crack pipes to people
or meth pipes and other
drugs syringes will just increase the
amount that they're actually doing so i
just want to mention one thing in
reference to this story if you do a
google search and look up harm reduction
supplies and safe smoking kits glass
stems crack pipes and meth pipes are
typically included in them now that
we've gotten that out of the way i don't
know if our good friends from congress
have any insights into the story or what
was going on is it true is it false and
what do you think about it
um i would like to say that fact checker
itself i reject the phrase i mean it's a
synonym for corporate shill or leftist
propagandist amen so
that's my take on fact checkers well
believe a word they say no i don't
believe a word they say either and
actually i find it appalling that joe
biden and the biden administration would
give out crack pipes in these safe
smoking kits you know we do want to see
people get off of drugs i think that's
extremely important but i think biden
doesn't care about drugs he doesn't care
about people dying fentanyl is coming
across our border at a
terrible rate um fentanyl poisoning is
now the number one cause of death uh of
ages 18 to 45 years old and so joe
biden's all for drug use right he's all
for fentanyl he's all for smoking meth
smoking crack whatever it may be
it's absolutely appalling but the one
thing he doesn't support the one safe
drug he doesn't support is ivermectin so
i think this is a serious problem well
as always people should be getting
medical advice from trusted medical
professionals and i don't care if it's a
politician i don't care if it's a
celebrity you got to get that advice
from somewhere else the story the part
of the story that makes me laugh is okay
let's just say for a minute all right
there's no crack pipes here right
they've denied it no crack pipes does
the safe smoking kit include meth pipes
then because that's typically involved
the issue is even snopes acknowledged
the point of this program is to give
priority to minorities
to smoke
these drugs
so that means that think about this for
two seconds like the bite administration
is basically saying we're going to be
funding
programs that distribute drugs and and
drug paraphernalia to minorities i don't
think that's going to solve the problem
of racism are they actually distributing
drugs as well or is this just a
paraphernalia program i think it's
paraphernalia okay just make sure it's
clear clarified like syringes and stuff
like that but if like i'll put it this
way if there's like a white dude he's a
drug addict there's like a black dude
he's a drug addict and your program says
give the drug the supplies to the to the
minority that means you're gonna have
less white people doing drugs and more
minorities doing drugs that sounds
awfully racist or more more white people
getting sick from from dirty needles and
and that's also horrible and raising
wait a minute wait a minute have we we
haven't voted on any funding for this
how are they doing it
we've given them broad swaths i don't
know how they do it i don't remember
reading this in any building we have
voted on one thing though in our
judiciary committee
and that is to make sure there's parity
in drug sentencing laws between crack
and powder cocaine because
in the beginning
it was actually the the african-american
communities who wanted maximum sentences
for these evil people that were
destroying their communities for crack
they should
but then they decided that it was racist
to over prosecute crack in comparison to
powder cocaine so a lot of states have
made it uh made parity between the
sentencing laws between these two and so
we've had votes in congress to restore
parity to get rid of any racial bias i
don't think people should be going to
prison for doing drugs i think they need
help i don't know how do you guys feel
about that
i think drugs are so destructive i mean
like i said right now the drugs that are
coming across the border just a record
rate
through the mexican cartels are laced
with fentanyl and if if young people are
dying if the number one cause of death
for young people is fentanyl poisoning i
think drugs are a real problem i really
do is it is it number one it's number
one number one cause of death it's not
coveted 19. it's fentanyl poisoning no i
think we have the constitutional
authority to regulate it at the border
but uh let's be honest when they wanted
to outlaw alcohol
they recognized at the time they had to
do it through a constitutional amendment
so
states might be able to do this and the
feds might be able to do it at the
border but i don't think we have the
constitutional authority to ban
substances at the federal government
level yeah i mean honestly i agree i
don't i think you know the problem is we
talked about a bit last night
we want people to not do drugs
and so
personally i think locking people in
prison for imbibing something sounds
really really awful especially if it's
something hurting them and they're
addicted and they need help
so you look at these other countries you
know portugal was big but they offer
people help you know my understanding is
it's still illegal to do these things in
public
giving out these supplies and funding
the stuff seems like they read a
pamphlet about it and then decided to
throw money on it without actually
investigating what it's going to do
because it sounds good i just watched
leanna wen from cnn talking about how i
think times are changing the science has
changed and things are changing and now
we got to think about how depression and
how like despair is doing damage to
people so maybe this is a way to help
people cope with their despair because
maybe drug addiction is up i wouldn't be
surprised sure joe biden's like have a
crack pipe
yeah well and also throughout the
pandemic deaths from drug overdoses have
increased yeah so is suicide yes it's
tragic it really is
but if it saves just one life right yeah
i love the facts on this though like you
were mentioning fact checkers isn't it
kind of crazy there at that point where
fact checkers for the most part obscure
the facts to make it harder for you to
understand what's going on
yeah that's
and the question is what is their
purpose and who is paying them i dug
deep into factcheck.org and and looked
at their corporate records and they
receive funding from the robert wood
johnson foundation which holds two
billion dollars of j j stock which is a
vaccine manufacturer the money they
receive is earmarked for vaccine fact
checking what really yeah so i taught i
taunted them on twitter and dared them
to fact check me on on my facts on them
and so their fact checks
didn't deny the fact that they were
taking money from this organization as
two billion dollars of
vaccine manufacture stock they said that
i was wrong because the vaccine
manufacturer has no editorial con
control over what they say but i never
said that right and as if it matters to
be honest right they owned the fact
check program i didn't say they have
editorial control what's the name of the
company that's taking the 2 billion from
johnson johnson robert wood johnson
they they were started with johnson and
johnson stock it's one of the founders
of johnson johnson and they say they're
trying to diversify it but the reality
is they still hold two billion dollars
and they're getting
money from that do you know how much of
it is earmarked for um propaganda
i guess if that's the right word well
they give it to factcheck.org and their
entire program which is probably not a
big program it's like one leftist
reporter from pennsylvania somewhere
is funded with it and then they just pay
for ads with it or something like
facebook ads or they hire people yeah
they pay this one reporter who's not a
scientist so think about it the
taxpayers are funding the people to be
in charge of what's information and
what's misinformation what gets me is
that makes no sense if you draw a six on
a table and you ask one guy what is that
he says it's six the other guy says it's
a nine and then the fact checkers come
in they get to decide which one of us is
right and they get to decide who gets
banned who gets demonetized who gets
removed yep well and then here's what i
love about the science change like that
lyanna when woman or whatever is that
her name yeah yes that's a cnn doctor
she's like the science changed and now
all of a sudden they're trying to reopen
and the covid restrictions my problem
with this is
we have a ton of studies coming out of
india and sweden that say certain things
so just leave it at that
that's not the science changing that's
those studies are bad
then all of a sudden one study comes out
and they say oh look the science changed
we're going to change our policy
what no they're picking and choosing
what is the science apparently dr fauci
himself is the science and he decides
and then that's the direction they go
yeah i mean if you criticize him you're
criticizing science but yeah on the the
note of these fact checkers when you
look at snopes for example a couple
years ago there was a huge controversy
where they were fact-checking the
babylon b which publishes satire
articles and part of the issue with that
is it was actually
demoting their content in the algorithm
and just to give you an insight into how
honest this organization is referring to
snopes
they double down on this instead of
admitting that it was ridiculous to fact
check satire and they said we conducted
a study which showed that a lot of
people believe these articles are real
well this is what they did they took
headlines that were obviously jokes and
rewarded them to sound like they weren't
jokes so one example was democrats vow
to close dangerous gun buying loophole
known as the second amendment and that
was a babylon b article
it was rewarded by snopes to say cory
booker is one of several prominent
democrats to describe the second
amendment as a dangerous loophole that
allows people to buy guns and then they
asked people if they thought that was a
real story and when people said yes they
said see that means they believed the
satirical babylon b headline was true
it's true it's truly amazing isn't it
well they're in charge of the
information or at least they've put
themselves in charge of the information
but just as thomas was just pointing out
the taxpayers are funding
them to be in charge of the information
by the way quick story when the vaccines
first came out the pfizer data the top
line data was out there and the cdc
issued a report and said that it was the
vaccine
data showed that the vaccine was 92
efficacious if you'd already had covid
and i thought well that's a remarkable
claim
and so i went and looked at the data and
it showed it was there was actually a
negative correlation for those who had
already had covet if they took the
vaccine this is pfizer's own trial data
so i'm a congressman i called up the cdc
and they took my call surprising right
yeah and the director
in washington dc said i'll get my top
scientists on the line i said i think
it's a typo so she she calls me back
with her top scientists and she said
we're going to call you eagle eye massey
we don't know how we printed this we
it's a mistake we don't know how it made
it in here and i was like well okay well
you're going to fix it right oh yeah
we'll fix it and i said so are you going
to are you going to do an errata
are you going to change the pdf that's
up there like i got into the
technicalities
and so i thought it was all fixed
the vaccine comes out
older people in kentucky couldn't get it
because younger people were taking it
who had already had coven
but the data was never fixed the data
was never a month later somebody said oh
the cdc says this i went back and look
they never fixed the lie and the the lie
is obvious it's knowable today so you're
saying there's a negative correlative
data meaning that after someone received
the vax or if someone had received code
and then they got vaccine there was a
less was less resistance than if they
hadn't had covenant got the best it was
minus seven percent but they had so
little data it's hard to draw any
conclusion like the fact that they even
claimed they could say it was 92
was ridiculous this is early on earlier
this was when the vaccine first came out
this was early december december 14th of
2020 right well as it's gone on though
we've learned more but really the truth
is when there's talking about the
science changing like she was talking
about on cnn y'all it has nothing to do
with science it's all about polling it's
about politics and this is an election
year and this is why democrats are
starting to loosen up we saw new jersey
taking away their mass mandates other
states and they're easing off because
they know they're in trouble this is a
major issue parents do not want their
kids masked i will i will issue the
obligatory talk to your medical
professional about what's right for you
and
data changes so make sure you're double
checking a lot of the stuff because uh
you know we don't have anything pulled
up but uh youtube is very very gruesome
these days by the way i have a
recordings of those phone calls that's
what i was going to ask you do you
normally record everything when you make
calls to these people no i normally do
not it's not something i would ever do
with another congressman for instance
but you publish them uh i gave them to
cheryl atkinson who did sort of an
expose and she picked the portions of
the phone calls i mean there there's
like an hour of recordings because i
published five or six
i should just release them all yeah yeah
yeah absolutely well let's talk let's
talk about the polling date and how it's
changing so you know uh margery you're
just mentioning
it's not about science it's about
polling right now we're seeing you know
new york illinois you mentioned new
jersey they're starting to pull back on
their mandates we have the story from
timcast.com president biden's approval
rating falls below 40 according to new
poll the rate marks an all-time average
low for biden at 30 was it 39.8 in the
real clear politics average that is i
believe like two two or three points
lower than where donald trump was at the
same time in his presidency
i think it's fair to say the democrats
have gotten the message when you look at
civics data
it's a website the civic spell of the
queue
you can see that on economics on covid
on the direction of government
independent voters and republicans are
very much in alignment republicans
absolutely think the economy is trash
independent voters think the economy is
very very bad democrat voters think the
economy is good somehow i don't know why
they must be watching too much cnn yes
but that tracks true for almost every
issue wow black lives matter support uh
the covid response democrats think joe
biden did a great job independent voters
republicans are kind of like well
republicans are like it's miserable
independent voters are like it's pretty
bad so so you know it's it's weird
that we have democrats the voter base
believing something that most americans
or at least independent voters
republicans don't i think obviously it's
media
but i think the media narrative is
breaking that's why democrats are going
down in the polls so it's not even just
the polls it's that they've lost control
of the narrative which results in the
polls tanking which results in them
saying whatever they got to say to try
and win especially this year
i totally agree well you can't lie to
people over and over when they see
something different in their everyday
life when they're going to the gas pump
and gas is up to almost four dollars a
gallon when they're going to the grocery
store and the store shelves are empty
and and food prices have gone up and
then when they're taking their kids to
school and their children are healthy
and no one their children are just fine
after two years of covered 19 but yet
they're still being forced to wear masks
and then there's children you know
suffering like with speech therapy and
different type of you know special needs
kids these masks are terrible for them
and and so yeah it's it is a real issue
and you can't lie to people over and
over again on the news and when they see
something different in their everyday
life stacy abrams
alyssa slotkin
you know stacey abram's sitting out with
all these kids wearing masks and she's
not doing it yeah i mean they're
basically telling you they don't care
they don't care let me say something
about stacey abrams because she's
running for governor in my state that
picture was infuriating to me i'm a mom
i've got three kids now my kids are
older but stacey abrams she is in the
height one of the highest risk factors
for coven 19 she's obese she is she's
obese i'm not trying to say anything
terrible about anyone but that is the
state of her health
she's sitting on the floor without a
mask in front of all these children who
who are not at high risk of covid19 that
those are the facts that's on the cdc
that is the data that science has not
changed
she sits there without a mask i mean it
was infuriating to me there's no way
parents in georgia to want that woman to
be the governor of our state when that's
how she views children that she is
better than them and that they have to
sit there with a mask on while she gets
to take hers off why did she do it did
you guys know what was the purpose of
that photo it was really really badly
right for her it's not the first time
we've seen a democrat who advocates for
masks not wear one
a picture recently of obama we saw nancy
pelosi getting her hair done we saw
whitmer the same thing i think they're
just liars
they're they're lying about how they
really feel about masks and if they want
they if they don't do you see that video
of rashida taleb saying she's on camera
saying something like i only wear this
when the republicans are around or
they're filming me or something it's
it's it's the weirdest we can talk about
masks i'm gonna let thomas start
in the house of representatives there's
a rule that you have to wear a mask but
guess what it only applies when you're
in front of cameras huh what yes no yes
yes either the only place they enforce
the rule is in a committee where there
are cameras or on the floor of the house
not in the hallways and when you go in
the hallways oh wow you'll see democrats
take their masks off it's been that way
for over a year the whole yeah it's been
there ever since i it's been that way
the whole time for me only if there's
cameras sure now is that
is it but i don't wear mine is that
codified in the rules like it says in
the presence of cameras or no it doesn't
say in the presence of cameras
functionally they just don't enforce it
unless cameras are around they
functionally do not enforce it anywhere
but on the floor or
in a committee where they're incredible
where i have over 100 000 in mask fines
and uh my good friend thomas massey and
i have something fun going on i'm going
to let you tell so uh one day pelosi
goes out the the media says when are you
going to lift the masks fines or the
masks rule in the house because remember
there was a period of time where if
you'd been vaccinated you could take
your mask off right and most of congress
had been vaccinated so they asked pelosi
and she said until every member of
congress is vaccinated everybody's going
to wear a mask and i realized okay the
mask rule is now morphing into a vaccine
rule
and so i organized i don't want to say i
led but i organized 10 members of
congress and marjorie was among them to
go to the floor of the house and
notoriously and openly violate this mask
rule
in front of the c-span cameras and we
were promptly fined for our
transgressions and if she had just sent
the bill to georgia for marjorie's case
or to kentucky in my case
she would have been fine we would have
thrown them in the trash and she
wouldn't have got her money
but what she did is she reduced our
salaries that's right whoa takes it off
on the front end how does she do that
well she violates the constitution to do
it because the constitution says that
the salaries are set by law and drawn
from the treasury to be set by law a law
has to pass the senate and be signed by
the president the 27th amendment to the
constitution the very last one to be
ratified ratified in 1992 but suggested
during the bill of rights says that
congressional salaries can't vary
without an intervening election
now why did they do that a lot of people
think it was so we wouldn't give
ourselves a raise that could be partly
true but in reality if you go back and
look at the debates they decided if
anybody could get control of a person's
sustenance of their salary they could
bend their will pretty easily and so
they made sure that you couldn't vary it
until there was an election such a rich
yeah then but even that i mean
marjorie's got a hundred thousand
dollars of fines oh the next thing they
did because they figured out they can't
stop me from refusing to wear a mask
because they figured out i truly will
not stop doing it no matter how much
they find me and we are going to have a
very successful lawsuit i'm thrilled
about it um he's explained it perfectly
so they sent a letter uh a letter was
sent to sergeant-at-arms saying that
they should put anyone without a mask up
and up into the coveted box and and no
one really no the public doesn't know
about the coveted box because it's not
in view of the c-span cameras the
coveted box nancy pelosi had it built
right before this the vote for speaker
of the house in january of 2021
it is a plexi glass box up in the corner
of the house chamber now the plexiglas
doesn't go all the way to the ceiling
and it's supposed to be the the original
design was for any house member uh to go
there if they were sick or having
symptoms of covid19 it wasn't for well
people uh unvaccinated people or people
without masks it was only for sick
people but then catherine clark who who
called representative catholic
representative catherine clark sent a
letter to the sergeant-at-arms because
they're so offended um at me or any or
thomas or anyone not wearing a mask and
they want to put us up in the in the
covered box in the penalty box yeah
sounds like we're going to check you up
into the penalty box this is beyond
i i when i think about how bad congress
is you know the first time you came
marjorie explained how they don't even
really vote on the bills they just like
i nay and then just like don it sounds
like congress isn't a real thing it's
like it's like a theater to make
americans think there's something
actually being done about our problems
speaking of theater do you remember the
title of this person who wants us in the
box now yes oh yes what was her title
assistant speaker assistant speaker of
the house we think that her real title
is assistant to the speaker right and
then she just marked out that's what's
that's a joke from the office yeah
that's right
i think it's funny that we're all
sitting here laughing and it sounds like
the institution is just completely in
decay and falling oh it gets worse we
can tell you more well i i was the guy
that everybody hated by the way i was
the most hated person in washington dc
now i'm just the most hated man now that
marjorie is there but before marjorie
got there in 2020 march 27 2020 tenth
day of flattening the curve congress
decided to spend two trillion dollars
with nobody there and taking no vote
this is my favorite story thomas massey
story one of my favorites i got in the
car and drove to washington dc and
objected and i said the constitution
requires a quorum to be here in order to
pass this bill and they hated me nancy
pelosi called me a dangerous nuisance
tell him what a quorum is a quorum would
be
at least half of congress needs to show
up to pass which is how many people 218.
how many how many were there well they
were going to do it with one in the
speaker's chair and one on the floor
they were going to do it with two people
that's like it so remember i was telling
you they they'll pass bills with only a
couple people in there saying yes or no
that is exactly what he's talking about
they were going to spend how much money
two trillion dollars with two people in
there the speaker and one other person
so they they said it was too dangerous
for them to come and vote meanwhile
they're going to the grocery store and
expecting a grocer to be there and
somebody to bag their groceries they
expect the truck drivers to be driving
they expect the ups guy to show up the
nurses to be there unvaccinated
healthcare workers right nobody was
vaccinated at the time by the way
so anyways i i stood up i objected i
said i'm here today to make sure that
our our republic doesn't die in an empty
chamber by unanimous consent is it like
a cryptographic uh vulnerability to vote
by just vote digitally and then confirm
it with a video chat
well okay they they hadn't by the way i
think they need a constitutional
amendment to do that
um
what they have come up with since then
is a vote by proxy where a human being
tells another human being on the floor
vote for me this way so that they can't
be compromised it's basically human so
it works like this i say to my friend
thomas massey i'm going to just stay in
georgia this week while congress is in
session thomas will you vote for me and
then thomas goes sure i'll be your proxy
and so i can i've never done this by the
way and i will not do it and i haven't
either yeah we don't participate but
this is what members of congress do some
of them have just hardly ever shown up
literally hardly ever shown up and
someone else just votes for them so this
is like a representative having a
representative that sounds like they're
not doing their job
they're not doing their job unless you
count their job as going to fundraisers
i mean they will literally attend
fundraisers that's right instead of
coming to votes
do you think term limits will end these
these fun non-stop fundraisers i don't
think so
i i don't think i mean i've sponsored
term limits i'm for term limits let's
try it
but i'm for it the problem is not that
the people who've been there a long time
sell out it's the problem is that people
get there and sell out on day one
and then you have people who announce
their retirements and you would think
well now they're unchained they they've
no obligations and they'll vote their
conscience
no they once they know that they're no
longer going to be there the voting
record doesn't improve if anything their
attendance goes down and yeah
adviser or something the ones that are
retiring i'll give you an example adam
kinzinger
that's well we don't know what he is
what is he
he's nancy pelosi's little little baby
boy so anyways adam kenzinger he he
voted yes with the democrats competes
act last week he was the only republican
to vote yes for it so he's not running
for congress again so he has completely
sold out and voting whichever way the
democrats are happy with but um back to
thomas's story
which how much of this do you want me to
tell it's up to you oh my gosh i had
president trump yelling at me oh my
he called me up that day for the for the
having the audacity to say that members
of congress should show up and vote
yelling at you for what
uh
i don't know he was afraid it might slow
down the process of getting two trillion
dollars out the door and twelve hundred
dollar checks in the mailbox well let's
reference whether you remember this it
was in march of 2020 it was the shutdown
no one knew what covid was going to do
everyone was freaking out people they
didn't know what the outcome was going
to be so president trump was pushing
through
thomas massey was trying to say no we
have to do this correctly we still have
a constitution that has not gone away
and i'm proud of him i totally support
him for what he did so he said he said
he would on the phone he told me he was
going to come at me like i'd never seen
never
never in your life before have you seen
the way in which i will come at you
awesome yeah
i feel like he also reminded me which is
true he's more popular than me in
kentucky
and he said it would be the end of me
and i i tried to tell him this was
constitutional and we needed to do it
this way and it would still pass anyway
because most people were for it we just
couldn't break the constitution today
and he repeated you know i'm coming at
you like you've never seen never in your
life before have you seen the way in
which i will come at you and then he he
said that i was a
he i didn't know what that meant but
before i got back to my seat i i found
out
he said i was a third-rate grandstander
on twitter
on twitter yeah and you're in trouble
when that happens yeah and that i should
be thrown out of the gop and
and some other stuff so when i walked
out of the floor having objected and
making everybody show up to work which
they hated by the way they still
wouldn't take a recorded vote even
though they had a quorum they would not
put their names on that bill and when i
walked out the the press wanted to know
what i had to say for myself that my own
president had called me a third-rate
grandstander and i looked at him i said
i was offended i'm at least second rate
[Laughter]
did you guys see that story
it was it was several months ago
actually but video recently got released
of planes coming into new york carrying
illegal immigrants undocumented so uh
they were being uh shuffled into i think
tennessee and the uh the biden
administration was using military
flights air force to bring you know
undocumented kids illegal immigrants
across the country we got video released
of one of these moments so there was a
big story about these planes landing in
westchester new york
video body camera footage is released so
these co these federal contractors
refusing to show id refusing to explain
what they're doing the police who are
doing security at the airport are like
what are what is this this flight is
past curfew you're not supposed to be
landing who are these people where are
their ids and then one of the federal
contractors said something to the effect
of if the american you know you know
help us if the american people find out
what's what's going on what we're doing
and the cop says why and he goes because
the government has betrayed the people
and that's a line from this leaked
footage of the new york post had this i
see stories like that
and it makes and everything you're
telling me right now
and it really feels to me you know one
of the reasons the media dislikes you
guys so much especially you marjorie is
because
you are regular people and you've
somehow got into the room and they're
they're they're you know they're holding
their wine glasses pinkies i'm like oh
heavens you know like the help is in
here like what do we do like the please
pretty sure they said that you you guys
both you guys both were like basically
independently wealthy or and had enough
that you didn't need to make money out
of congress when you got there i would
imagine i know you said you had a
construction company yes we have a
construction company but for me it was
more about i i've i've got so
disappointed in republicans not doing
what they said they were going to do and
i just got so concerned and i thought
you know what i'm going to run for
congress and and hold them accountable
and actually i want to be part of a
republican conference that does the
things that say that we say we're about
and also i mean i i'm i never apologize
for this and i and i always say it i'm
very proud i've always supported
president trump and i loved his policies
and so when i was running for congress
he was running for reelection for a
second term and that was something i
wanted to be a part of i really wanted
to be a part of a republican member of
congress
hopefully finishing out his america
first agenda um now i i don't like the
spending i'm also honest about that i
want to see or we should have a balanced
budget actually i'd like to see a budget
that makes a profit i'd like to pay off
the debt these are things that i think
we should be working towards but um he
was the first uh you know president that
i was that i believed in because i felt
like every other politician and and most
of the time they've been selling out our
country they've moved for decades
they've moved us into this global
economy which is hurting every single
american that's outside of politics
that's selling our country out and so
you know not not it wasn't about money
or a career choice at all for me it was
about i feel like i have to do this you
know for my kid's future and and i
didn't trust anyone else to do it when
you think about
debt do you think that we could default
on the
interest to the federal reserve
i think we have serious problems i don't
think our dollar is is going to be worth
anything pretty soon and i think uh
china is is has positioned itself so
well and because of our politicians who
have have moved us into this i mean
we're hunter biden hunter biden should
be in jail but there's many other people
dianne feinstein many of the other
people who have have positioned and and
worked america into these these this
global economy and and companies
corporations and their interests you
know i i really worry about the dollar
being worth anything at all with
everything we've seen that you know
inspired you both to get involved in
congress
how optimistic or pessimistic are you do
you you think we're doomed do you think
you know we've got sunshine heading our
ways or what's going on
well let me let me clarify something ian
said first i'm not independently wealthy
i'm just independent
i live off the grid we raise a lot of
our own food
i don't need the job if i didn't have
the job we could go back and sustain
ourselves on our farm and so that's
where i draw my strength not that i've
got a big bank account yeah wealth
doesn't even mean money well you know
don't need it we don't need it i mean um
so um so that's where i draw my strength
when i go to mordor just want to call it
you know so are you guys
optimistic based on your time look look
i'll put it this way you you've told us
a lot already that's like
really bad you know the covet box the
not voting on things are trying to
shuffle through trillions of dollars and
i'm just like you've got to be
particularly jaded at this point right
so i i'm jaded but i'm not apathetic i
still want to fight but the process is
getting worse and worse rank and file
members are excluded from the actual
legislative process
more and more the only vote you take
that matters is at the beginning of the
year when you vote for speaker and then
basically there's a top-down
structure that's in control of the
legislation this is why to ian's point
about term limits there are permanent
staff there i'm not talking about the
staff that work in marjorie's office or
my office but they're i call him the
deep congress there's the the staff that
will be there when we are long gone and
they were there before us and if when
they so choose they could go work on k
street or maybe they came from there
term limits for
staff
that would be a big deal that would be a
huge deal because he's right thomas is
right the staff never leaves but members
of congress come and go how do i feel i
always have hope um i'm a christian i'm
very open about my christian faith so i
always keep hope and and and i think
that's the best way to look at every
single situation we find ourselves in no
matter how dark it looks i will tell you
what happened this past week what we
found out through our one of our
colleagues troy nels from texas um the
story he told about one of his staff on
november 20th coming into his office
during thanksgiving week
and finding capitol police in his office
that had been taking pictures of
congressman nell's um white board and
things in his office and then
questioning his staff
without a warrant or anything like that
questioning him about things on the
whiteboard that that terrified me but
then we also found out louis gomer louis
gomer uh congressman louis gomer from
texas also told a story and showed
evidence he actually showed it a mail
that was supposed to come to him to his
office but it went to the department of
justice and then the department of
justice had opened the mail restamped it
and then they delivered it to him that
should never happen and then what i've
been through um you know in our office
buildings are closed to the public right
now public cannot come in unless you get
permission from one of our offices
but there's people that work in the
building that vandalize and attack signs
right outside my office door and those
are people that work in the building the
the amount of death threats i receive
are in you know some of the top um of
all members of congress that concerns me
for my own safety so when we're adding
up all these things and and we don't
know what's going on
it's it's terrifying i don't this should
never happen in in our in our congress
i've requested for months i have asked
over and over for the sergeant-at-arms
and capitol police to put us a camera in
the hallway right above my office and
guess what no camera it should be live
streamed i mean that could be they can
pay for they can pay for illegals to fly
across the country in the middle of the
night and we haven't voted on that have
we in secret if not and then the
contractors admit to the body cameras
that they've betrayed the country i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna
jump right into that uh that hot tub and
say it if you're if we're at the point
where the public is barred from these
buildings
and political rivals who who work there
are vandalizing your offices when you've
got accusations let alone if it's true
like maybe maybe troy's wrong about this
maybe the capital piece are right it
doesn't matter when you have such a hard
divide where one side says capitol
police dressed as construction workers
broke into my office photographed
protected materials and then
interrogated my staff a few days later
about it
civil war
i mean if the january 6 committee if
democratic establishment uniparty
players are willing to use law
enforcement and
vandalism physical attacks
to get their way to win
if they're going to subpoena the former
administration his staff and members of
the media costing them hundreds of
thousands of dollars we are beyond
elected representative government it is
now ruled by force whoever can command
the most amount of power this is the
precursor in my opinion to hot civil war
tim i think you're perfectly phrasing
the way most people feel when they're
watching what's happening in washington
dc it's it's it's not what happens in
america this is what we see happen in
communist countries this is where we see
you know some people rise up and and
topple the regime that's in control and
then they become the next dictator this
is we don't see this in america i i stay
away from the term civil war i do not
like it because i don't like violence i
i was very upset on january 6 with that
riot it was it was the worst day of my
life i'd just never seen anything like
it so that is not something i i go near
but i will say this shouldn't happen
this we shouldn't be treated like
political enemies in such a way where
they may be spying on you know sending
people to spy on our legislation or or
or not protecting our lives like i feel
like they're not protecting my life um
or you know
putting us making us go through metal
detectors to go vote where the entire
room is on camera it just it's it's
totally out of control one of the things
that um was floated the last time we
talked to you was that
democratic groups are going to try and
use legis uh lawsuits the judicial
system to bar you from re-election and
we're seeing that now with madison
hawthorne they've filed claiming he's an
insurrectionist for speaking at a rally
thus he's ineligible for office
that is
shockingly dangerous because what
happens when
you get a partisan judge who agrees or
disagrees and then one side or the other
side says oh they only issued this
ruling because of their affiliation and
then let's say let's say they do
disqualify madison cawthorn is he going
to just be like well i guess i'm not in
congress anymore or is he going to say
no i'm the duly elected representative
and i'm going to to the capitol and then
what happens when the police bar him
from entry what happens to the people in
his state who expect representation when
they don't get it
well marjorie saw this she was punished
for something that happened before she
was elected and they won't even say what
it was she was removed from all of her
committees now she was still allowed as
a congressperson to be a congressperson
but it's kind of like
a second class they're trying to demote
her too because she has no committees
the the voters
litigate this okay the voters there's
750 000 to 800 000
people in every congressional district
and those people and those people alone
should decide if you are eligible if
you've done something that disqualifies
you it shouldn't be the party that's in
power when you get there who gets to
decide that's right the elections are
there for a purpose but what tim's
talking about is terrifying they're
trying to actually block madison
cawthorn from being allowed to be on the
ballot in north carolina um and so
that's why he's had to file that lawsuit
but here's something really interesting
so let's turn it a little bit maxine
waters went on the ground in minnesota
was it minnesota not even her home state
she's from california
so she goes down there and she's you
know basically inciting a riot inciting
violence no one moved to block her from
being on the ballot and so that's why
this this is totally out of control i
agree with thomas elections it should be
up to the people they should be able to
choose who their representative is but
this plan that was launched by mark
elias who is the democrat election
attorney and he's put he tweets about it
all the time on his twitter page mark
elias um this this is an this is a plan
that is uh way out of bounds completely
out of bounds i think it's one of the
most dangerous things i mean look what's
one congress person anyway i mean you
want to get your legislation passed then
my i would view the democrats as just
the appropriate thing to be to say was
let's try and win where we can win and
recognize we'll lose where we're going
to lose for them to go out and be like
let's file specialty lawsuits that
bypass elections to bar people we don't
like from being in congress
let me throw it to pennsylvania
where we had that uh lawsuit over
universal mail and voting which has
since been ruled unconstitutional
proving the republicans in that state
right and simultaneously wrong because
they were the ones who negotiated the
deal in the first place it was stupid
but that's besides the point
when it went to the lower court judge
the lower court judge said
on the merits of this lawsuit it seems
that universal mailing voting in
pennsylvania violates the constitution
and the republicans will likely win on
those merits it's got to go to a higher
court the higher court's public response
was
you guys are republicans and you took
too long so you lose
a judge shouldn't be looking at a person
and saying because of your political
affiliation i rule for or against you so
what happens when madison hawthorne goes
to this ghost he's filed a counter suit
arguing he is eligible for for to be on
the bout to run they go before a judge
maybe the judge is a democrat
the well-known democrat judge says not
lawsuits correct madison you're off the
ballot are the constituents of madison's
district going to be like okay we accept
that from this judge
or are they going to say no we have
voted on this and what do those people
do and what happens if madison then goes
to congress and says the people have
chosen me let me in and the capitol
police say no
see this is where it's getting in very
dangerous territory and that is that is
where people could be
invoked to do things they shouldn't have
to do i mean it's a terrible
scenario to even think about but here's
the ultimate goal what they really want
is if they can remove madison cawthorne
off of the ballot on north carolina they
can remove president trump and block him
from ever being allowed to be on the
ballot in north carolina and if if a
president if a presidential candidate
cannot be on one single state it's
impossible to win the election and it's
all about the elect electoral college
votes it's the count if he's not on
north carolina he cannot win if he's
running again in 2024. yeah i think it's
also more than that that may be the main
thing but
look it's about intimidating members of
congress because that congressional
district in north carolina is going to
send a republican to congress it's not
about them trying to
get some leverage in the majority and to
get another democrat there they are
trying to silence madison cawthorne and
if they can affect that then they will
have intimidated everybody else and now
they'll be more
cautious and careful and and about what
they say and and to be honest uh except
for marjorie republicans
republicans do scare very easily they're
very they're very scared of the new york
times opinion page you know uh often
they're more more concerned about the
opinion of the new york times and their
own constituents there are very few
politicians in general i mean look the
democrats tend to walk in lockstep they
capitulate to the far left relatively
often the republicans have a handful of
people who are principled and stand up
for the most part a lot of them are just
like i don't want to offend anybody i
better just play ball which is why you
end up with republican with democrats
saying ban all guns and republicans
saying no wait don't a strong republican
should be saying unban all the guns
exactly give them out to everybody well
that's what thomas says exactly well
that's why you guys are probably good
this is probably why dan crenshaw
canceled on us twice and i'm not trying
to be disrespectful but it's true dan
crenshaw agreed to come on the show he
had he canceled he said there was a vote
i said that's no big deal you owe us
nothing and well they communicate i'm
saying personally but you know the
communications with their producer and
then he was supposed to come on
yesterday and we got word there was a
scheduling conflict i mean this is this
is this is how it goes with the
overwhelming majority of politicians
there's very few that actually are
principled people who can speak candidly
and honestly and don't have to worry
about tripping over their own fake words
who who canceled today that you had to
invite marjorie and i
who canceled
them
they were like everyone get out margaery
and thomas are coming
alex jones is the greatest dude he has
been so cancelled he's a wild
entertainer
and a brilliant man isn't he fantastic
no one is perfect and everyone is
capable of incredible violence and
incredible love so yes
shout out to alex jones we love you and
i have no problem like they they they
try and i i don't know what these these
leftist media personalities think
they're getting by trying to insult me
or you know accuse me of things
because i literally don't care and it's
not going to change my i'm never going
to bend the knee to their stupid whims
or whatever alex jones is a journalist
and member of the media end of story you
don't you can say he's wrong you can say
he's fake news you could accuse him of
being incorrect and not fact-checking
and i think there's valid criticism in a
lot of what alex jones says absolutely
but he runs a media organization and so
when the january 6 commit committee
subpoenas him
they are basically violating our first
amendment protections the the press
isn't supposed to be
you know
the press can say what they want to say
and and and you know i love this was
really going to offend them all
alex jones is a journalist the same as
brian stelter and jake tapper and don
lemon are you absolutely i was actually
saying the same thing but some people
are going to be like don't insult alex
that way well yeah yeah alex jones never
lied us into a war right right right
so and why does the new york times and
cnn get to say that trump is guilty of
russia collusion yes when it was never
proven that it's actually proven
yeah i want to make a point you you
don't have to try and prove you're a
journalist to enjoy first amendment
protection also yeah exactly they're
occasionally
you know the big newspapers will come to
congress with suggestions for extra
protections that they might receive
and it should extend to anybody whether
there's one person listening to your
podcast
or whether they're
10 million people subscribing to your
newspaper i want to follow up on asking
about legalizing guns because i hear you
are interested in that when you talk
about that are you like tim sometimes
says repeal the second amendment i think
he's not in our own section
not repeal the second amendment that's
the opposite of that yeah what do you
say repeal all gun laws and make
everything like what about nuclear
weapons repeal the nfa and abolish the
agency so how far policy
how far do you take it with destructive
weaponry that you think people should be
legally allowed to possess
so well let's look to the purpose what
was the purpose of the constitution why
is the second amendment in there defense
well that's my opinion i think it's
there so that the government the
government doesn't have a monopoly on
force like it did in every other country
the people have the right to bear arms
in our country why is that it's so that
tyranny can't prevail in this country
can i elaborate on that i hear that a
lot and i think we can go deeper on that
tyranny doesn't need to come
domestically can come from foreign
adversaries right we can be conquered or
we can be corrupted from within the
right of the people to bear arms means
that as they that famous apocryphal
saying there's a gun behind every blade
of grass you ain't invading this country
at the same time
tyranny from within so to end's point
where do you draw the line right is it a
nuclear weapon what is it well first of
all let's let's acknowledge that
whatever the police have
to protect you when they get there you
should have until they get there okay so
anything any police department owns
should be fair game it whether you know
existing laws would ban it or not
i don't think that one person should be
able to take over a country they
shouldn't be one person shouldn't have a
weapon that
enables them to do that but the people
need to have sufficient weapons to throw
off tyranny and it can't be where like
99 percent agree that it's tyranny what
about cyber weapons
like the police has like hacking tools
and stuff
i don't think that applies to the second
amendment maybe not yet but i think
that's a there's a problem there there's
a problem there with the fourth
amendment
um are you saying that should people be
allowed to have them it's software it's
math
like i don't think you should ban it
there's no there's no
software code
we need some clarification is it illegal
to possess
a malware or a virus is it illegal to
position us
it is illegal to infect someone's
computer with a virus or malware but is
it legal to simply have it because if
it's not well it's legal to have guns
but it's not legal just go and shoot
somebody right yeah i wonder what levels
of of tech the police are using right
now to spy on people i know they have
things where they can like listen
through walls and
it doesn't matter what the technology is
if they're violating the constitution
this is the thing it's timeless
and so they don't have a warrant the the
police should not be able to use that
technology whatever it is what's that
thing they got where they fly they take
planes and they have this box that just
takes all cell phone data and just
breaks it i forgot what it's called
it's a
the police have this technology so
whenever this big protest you'll see
like a plane fly overhead or they set up
mobile cell sites and they have a device
that just takes
everything all of your text messages all
of your phone calls everything they get
at all they had those uh at many of the
the riots uh during 2020 and i don't
know if it's factual but i'd heard that
they had them on january 6th as well so
probably
i i wouldn't be surprised if the capital
has them just placed everywhere and
they're constantly spying on and
monitoring everyone's cell phone so the
first party question you say the police
the the local police we should be on par
with the police what about the military
so let's go back to the revolutionary
war because that's what was fresh in
their minds right when they wrote
wrote these uh articles and and then
later the constitution and the bill of
rights
you would need
the people need to have sufficient arms
that let's say if 30 to 40 percent tim
and i were talking about this before the
show if 30 to 40 percent could agree
that this was legitimate tyranny and it
needed to be thrown off
they need to have sufficient
power without asking for extra
permission it should be right there and
completely available to them in their
living room in order to to affect the
change and you know joe biden he has
that famous quote where he's like if you
want to take on the government you need
you know nuclear weapons which is just
not true that's not true at all the
crazy thing fighter jets can't occupy
street corners yeah well also how did we
lose afghanistan right oh look it wasn't
because they were nuclear power right
there yeah the taliban building nuclear
warheads and mervs the problem would be
like if one percent of the population
had weapons that were so strong that
they could take over well right this is
a good shot 20 percent
like i
believe i believe the second amendment
protects your right to own nuclear
weapons i believe an individual citizen
in this country has a right to own a
nuclear warhead but not a delivery
device oh all of it all of it i think
what about biological weapons
absolutely all of it
all of it
the con the second amendment does not
say the right to keep and bear arms will
not be infringed unless it can kill a
certain amount of people unless
it is a nuclear weapon unless it's a
biological weapon no no it says arms
arms arms arms nuclear arms biological
arms it says arms you got an issue with
that i can certainly understand why you
have to amend the constitution you
cannot just decide well we as a culture
hereby agree nuclear weapons are bad so
constitution doesn't matter anymore
no then you get together you have a
convention of states and you say we all
kind of agree
it's not that you want nuclear weapons
to be legalized but principally you
think they should be until we amend the
constitution it should not be hard to
amend that or do you principally think
we should do you principally think we
should have well hold on there a minute
um not necessarily but i do think it's
an interesting point you made thomas
that you know individuals should have
the ability to be at least on par with
the police i mean the police have a ton
of technology and weapons like lrads
acoustic weapons they have they've
experimented with light weapons and
other things that we don't have access
to they also have i'm pretty sure police
have select fire rifles which are
regulated under the nfa which we which
we have very difficult time getting but
if you if we're talking about let's
let's say we're gonna look at the
purpose of the second amendment and
that's why i wanted to add that portion
where it's not just about domestic
threats the idea that you have armed
militia ready and waiting means that if
a foreign adversary comes in the local
farmer is able to come out and fight
instead of being disarmed well that
really what's happening though just in
the event that china lands u-boats on
the shores of california and they've got
high-grade military tech directed energy
weapons scud missiles whatever well not
skirt missiles but cruise missiles what
do the american people have to resist
that as they invade if they invade and
it could happen here can i give you a
case that's not that abstract yeah and
may certainly be in play
i think putin's calculus in in ukraine
is not whether it takes him four hours
or four days to establish air dominance
over that country because it's certainly
not more than four weeks right the
question for putin is once you do that
are are your soldiers willing to walk
out in the street
when somebody in a jogging suit or in
their pajamas some grandma in their
pajamas in an apartment building in kiev
decides to blow your brains out and
you're just a soldier from russia that
wants to go home and be with his wife
and kids exactly
that that ultimately is the calculus
that putin is making it's a calculus
anybody should make before you go into
afghanistan or something like that do
the people
who
who own the stuff are they willing is a
certain minority a certain group of them
willing to
defend it with their life if they're not
then it's not their country it won't it
won't be their country for long a
dictator will take over internally or
externally and what weapons do they have
are they willing to die for it and what
weaponry are they are they willing to
use that's a fantastic
allegory thank you well i think one way
we can look at this i know in georgia
right now we really want constitutional
carry that's something that's being
pushed very hard i believe the georgia
senate is about to pass it we're hoping
that the house will pass it and our
governor will sign it into law but
talking about people invading our
country that's happening at the southern
border every single day and you talk
about farmers we had a house freedom
caucus we had a panel and we had border
patrol agents come in and many different
people and one of them was a retired
border patrol agent and he has a family
farm that is right there at the border
and he was telling the stories of he he
hates to leave his house because he'll
be leaving his wife and young children
there by themself and they constantly
have illegal aliens coming right across
their yard right by the house they have
them come up to the door and he feels
that he has to be there all of the time
to defend his wife and children because
he has guns and so when you talk about a
country being invaded we are a country
being invaded we're being invaded
non-stop every single day at the
southern border because the current
administration refuses
to secure our border and so it's it is a
serious issue the second amendment is so
important and and yeah i believe we have
to be able to have our i think uh uh
that was an understatement not that
they're refusing to cure our borders but
they're aiding and abetting people who
are entering illegally yes the bite
administration has been taking these
people and putting them on planes and
flying them to other states when the
biggest stories the biggest scandals was
and republicans in tennessee got wind
that in the dead of night they were
bringing underage undocumented children
via military plane into their state
without telling them and then just
releasing them into communities i mean
look
that that is beyond just having a weak
border that is hey let's taxi you to
wherever you need to go and we'll help
you get there i mean that's that's
insane to me and it's worse than that
look at what we do with foreign aid
every year we send just millions and
billions of dollars in foreign aid to
these countries guatemala central
america mexico all of these countries we
send this money to these basically these
governments that aren't taking care of
their people and we don't even know what
they're doing with that money we don't
even demand an account i would like to
see an account of what are you doing
with this money
personally i'd like to cut it all off
and keep all that money back here at
home but then these countries these
leaders these governments who we're
paying
send their people they just let them go
and send them up here to invade our
country i mean this is insanity and it
should just never be happening rather
than us giving foreign aid to other
countries why doesn't the federal
reserve just print the money for them
and leave us out of it
well what's the what's the difference
yeah why do we have to pass it through
our government just to make us feel good
about it it's still flooding uh the the
saturating by the way we'll document it
and cut out the middlemen by the way a
lot of those 1200 dollar checks went to
people overseas who were not americans
they didn't have a green card oh i see
because then there's little to no
oversight because we have yet to audit
the federal reserve
we haven't done that yeah we do we
should
totally audit the thing uh so so let me
ask you some questions you're stripped
of your committees are you able to write
up bills and stuff what is that what
does that mean for you know oh yeah i
can i can write bills submit bills um
i've co-sponsored some of thomas
massey's bills he's co-sponsored some of
mine fire fouchy we are totally all
about getting rid of anthony fauci um no
i operate completely as all the other
members of congress i just don't have
have to be a republican that sits on a
useless committee because democrats are
fully in charge right now that's
actually it's been a great thing i think
i've had the advantage of learning more
and working harder on the outside
being without committees
in this congress especially when
republicans are in the minority but the
good news is i get committees back the
next time okay have you have either of
you drafted legislation to either repeal
the nfa abolish the atf or audit the fed
abolish the atf you you did that one yes
yes
beautiful yes very good i've introduced
audit the fed every year that oh every
year so yeah i should have known
sponsored it i'm got to make sure i'm a
co-sponsor and uh uh does does rand paul
do that in the senate i believe he's big
on that isn't he
oh yeah yeah oh i'm on it
him and bernie were working on that
weren't they interestingly enough oh
bernie's had a change of heart bernie
was all for it when he was in the house
and a lot of these senators were for it
when they were in the house we've passed
it through the house and then it goes to
the senate and then people that
magically had this epiphany when they
got to the senate that we shouldn't
audit the fed yeah it's kind of like how
he had that magic epiphany that
millionaires weren't bad anymore once he
became one now it's just billionaires
right if you want to have a house you
can write a book a good book it's true
you can do it
by the way i got i was getting when
trump was was gonna name uh betsy devos
to be the secretary of education i got
swamped with phone calls people were
telling me not to vote for and we had to
explain i'm in the house i'm not in the
senate so
that clearly you know the education
system has failed you on this point but
what she knows about crt you know what
they said they the people said that
that's just an excuse we know you can do
something so i did i wrote a bill a one
sentence bill because my colleagues a
lot of them don't have a long attention
span it says that
and i've reintroduced it it says the
department of education shall terminate
on december 31st
20 22. and that's the entire bill so now
when they call up and they're mad or
when they were calling up and they were
mad i said well
you know i've introduced a bill to
eliminate her job so you don't have to
worry about it because i don't think
that the president or his appointees
should decide how or what your children
learn amen yeah amen it's funny how when
it's you know donald trump they agree
with you but then as soon as you get a
bite and they're like well hold on there
a minute i'm kind of okay with it now my
problem with repeat with um ending the
education department is that it ends a
lot of people's livelihoods so a lot of
people behind the scenes are like oh f
that we're gonna we're gonna stop him
but if you can transmute the department
into some other useful tool or function
okay same with the federal reserve i
don't know i just want to cancel it i
want to create a new economic structure
and then you know port over but ian the
other day you were sort of making a
point about automation and how it's
inevitable and we don't want people to
do jobs that aren't useful and if the
department of education is unnecessary
those people should just be occupied is
it unnecessary
i've got those numbers there are 4 000
people at the department of education
none of them have written a book or
teach taught a class they make an
average of a hundred thousand dollars
wow we could take that money
which and and send it to the states
where the states could collect it and it
doesn't have to go through federal hands
and they could hire more teachers
for taxpayers imagine doing an actual
job yeah like a trade a real job
building houses and cleaning sewers and
then it's trying to be in a truck driver
a truck driver i think truck drivers do
pretty podcasters
but but imagine that making cartoons
you're working hard
you're driving your truck
long haul long nights cross country away
from your family
and then some
bureaucrat in the department of
education is getting six figures to do
what and your taxes are paying for them
it's your choices and it's the party of
empathy and compassion who cares about
the working class that is ensuring that
this will always be the state of affairs
they're for the worker i think or the
workers for example that we'd have it'd
free up 400 million which would
translate to i think 8 million per state
is that what that comes out to for
teachers to hire teachers that could be
a mass movement well well it should be a
mass movement yes yes but but is it also
possible that um you both could just
introduce more legislation to uh
terminate more departments within the
government i personally think we
shouldn't pass bills and create more
departments we need to get rid of
departments we need to reduce the size
of the federal government so that is the
biggest problem it's out of control so i
like where you're going with this you
know it's one sentence the department
education will terminate have you
considered that for any other department
cdc would be at the top of my list oh
yeah why is that
because they're counter to health
policies exactly like they have been
they've not just been a benign waste of
money they have been hurtful to health
it's not it's not economy versus health
by solely focusing on on the virus they
have neglected suicide diabetes uh
you know heart disease that was
something that also said but but is this
an issue we've been neglecting it's an
issue of government failure right is
there is there a private response that
would have been better i think the
department of justice is one we should
seriously look at they have weaponized
and gone after parents that are going to
school boards demanding uh about how
their children are being educated how
their children are being treated at
school the the department of justice has
completely gone way past their bounds
you guys ever see that movie with robin
williams
what was it called he's the comedian who
becomes president by accident or he went
he runs for office yeah what was that
what was that called we watched it and
it was it's kind of a weird movie
because it really feels like
it feels like propaganda almost it's you
know we had this period of the year 2006
where you know jon stewart was very
popular and people were like john
stewart should run for office with
stephen colbert or whatever and this
movie comes out where it turns out the
comedian realizes he shouldn't be
president and the people don't want a
populist leader they want experts who
know what to do and i watch that movie
i'm just i just find it so strange but
but anyway if you're looking for an
analog to what's really going on watch
idiocracy yeah
shortly but dietary here's my point
electrolytes we have plants crave we
have these tropes that the people want a
down-to-earth funny guy to be you know
the the the president or the leader and
you end up with the trump and i'm like
i'm wondering if the people would just
accept politicians who are like once i
get in i'm gonna vote to shut it all
down that's all i'll do uh you get your
money back you figure out what you want
to do with it and then we're gonna shut
down all these departments across the
board they want a plan they want to they
want to dream they want to
to just close their eyes and see the
world that you're envisioning i think
some people do some people do want that
yeah i mean i think
to be honest that's someone i would vote
for now maybe i'm a niche voter here but
one thing i really appreciate about both
of you is that you're actually talking
about reducing the size and scope of
government and terminating some of these
agencies and interestingly enough
whenever someone who's conservative
tries to do that and tries to go back to
the way things were as a conservative is
supposed to they're called an extremist
all the establishment conservative is
supposed to do is either a try to
maintain
the size of the government and maintain
the institutions which were all set up
by big government leftists in years
prior and the moment anyone tries to do
more than that and reduce the size and
scope of government they're an extremist
can i explain the feedback mechanism
that causes that to happen in congress
please do so you get selected for
committees based on it's almost like a
beauty pageant
and the the lobbyists are the judges
and the lobbyists who have their
interests in front of those committees
and so you have to get cheerleaders on k
street who want you to be on that
committee and oversee their stuff so
you're already self-selected for
perpetuating their things so that's why
on the armed services committee there
even when republicans get in charge
they're not likely to repeal the vaccine
mandate
because they are doing in large part
what the generals do when i was on the
science committee
nasa the people at nasa write those
bills and and send them over and say
this is what we want and the congressmen
are so busy and can't understand most of
it they rub or stamp it and it rolls
through and maybe some of it goes to
their district because they were chosen
to be on that committee because they
have something in their district that
that committee funds and it's important
to their constituents so that once they
get on they want to keep funding how do
we solve this
national divorce
yeah but that always will result in a
civil war it shouldn't it doesn't have
to so just like a married couple that
decides that you know we can no longer
be married this is not working they
resolve the situation in a court right
they don't they don't actually go to war
and or they shouldn't try to kill each
other maybe some of them do i don't know
but they dissolve it they dissolve their
marriage in a court and so essentially
really what national divorce should look
like is it should go back to how our
nation is founded where state rights
were far more important than the federal
government and the federal government's
role should be reduced down to a very
small role and state rights should be so
strong and so that you know if you want
to live in a state where everyone has to
be vaccinated everyone has to wear three
masks at least three maybe four and then
you want to have a more communist style
state government government and crts
taught in the school crt absolutely and
and all of these radical things are what
we call radical but they may love it
sounds like massachusetts or california
but they should be able to have that and
then if you're like like kentucky or or
georgia even or florida you want to have
a more conservative uh pro-traditional
family values let's say that you want to
say no
you can choose to be vaccinated or you
can choose to wear a mask and you want
to have a more free government you
should be able to have it and then
there's no interference the federal
government's not going to shrink itself
so so here's the issue though because
you know we had ron perlman he's the
celebrity played hellboy come out
recently and say republican states
should leave and we should leave and
this discussion about national divorce
has been around for a long time but what
people don't understand is that's
exactly what happened in the first civil
war it wasn't like you had all of the
states fighting in congress and then
also started shooting each other in fact
what actually happened first was several
states said we out and they went okay
bye and then i actually pulled up from
the library of congress in january of
1861 you had 11 states seceding to form
the confederacy and lincoln hadn't even
been inaugurated until march yeah it
wasn't until the south started seizing
forts
that the north said hey you can't do
this so what would happen in the event
of a national divorce sure you know
california illinois
new york might be like we're going to
canada or something but then all of a
sudden you're going to have
one state's got a nuclear arsenal and
they're going to say we're the true
government of the united states of
america and those nukes belong to us
and then
one of these states is whichever faction
is in control of dc or whatever they're
going to say no it's ours you can't take
it and we're going to then you know
relocate these weapons and that's that's
basically what happened with fort sumter
let me give two examples of of
successful secession in history that
everybody knows about and everybody
forgets about and once very specific to
your case
uh ukraine used to be part of the soviet
union
and they left there was there were a lot
of uh
of those
well i mean the soviet union collapsed
so did it i mean wouldn't you wouldn't
the soviet union call it a collapse if
america was sort of fragmented they
would look at us and say oh your federal
government got so unwieldy that's true
and you overextended your federal
reserve and your army and you collapsed
under your own weight and now you're
separate states that's true okay so it's
been done there but it's also been done
in the united states there's one example
and i was born in the state that seceded
that nobody talks about and it's
successfully seceded west virginia
excuse me june of june of 1861 residents
of the western counties of virginia did
not wish to secede along with the rest
of the state this section of virginia
was admitted into the union as a state
of west virginia on june 20th 1863. so
they separate they seceded from the
confederacy
and but to do so they had to split a
state in half
and it's been totally accepted we go on
with life as if it's normal that a state
just said you know we're going to
separate they didn't go back together
when when virginia came back into the
union so a state has separate a state
has seceded from a state it's happened
what about north and south carolina
north and south dakota were they once
dakota and carolina
no yeah i think they were always maybe
territories for a brief moment gotcha
but i don't i don't think i think it's
naive to believe that the united states
is always going to exist in these
perfect 50 states
under this you know under the federal
government that keeps expanding and
expanding and expanding and i think it's
irrational for people to think that
americans are just going to sit idly by
while our federal government completely
becomes tyrannical and out of control
like we've watched it do over the past
year and um no one wants violence and
i'll say again i'm completely against
the civil war even though the media
tries to say i say things like that i
never do but i do truly believe that if
this becomes such a broken nation
and we have one party that is trying to
rule over like the democrats are trying
to rule over republicans
to the point where they are deciding
what opinion we're allowed to say
whether we can get whether we can stay
on social media or we have to leave
because we're
spreading what they claim is
misinformation if they get to a point
where they're saying we're going to
control your um what you're allowed to
do with your body and and what you have
to have injected into your body and you
have no no choice or say they're coming
to the point where they're saying this
is what your children have to be taught
and parents you have no input or say and
your and your children essentially
belong to the state like some people are
actually saying out loud and that's
happening in the state of california and
elsewhere when it gets to that point
it you can't you can't just accept or
think that americans are going to accept
it that is when it's okay to start
saying you know what just like in a
marriage i don't like the way you're
treating me you you either have to
change i'm asking you to change which is
what republicans should be saying to
democrats right now stop this behavior
you have to change we all have to live
here together we should care about our
country together and if you're not then
we need to consider maybe we need to
separate and what does that look like
but if there's one thing i think we've
learned it's that the left
absolutely believes it should rule over
the right exactly and that's just
authoritarianism in general this idea of
a leftist this weird authoritarian bent
whatever the libertarian side of things
are the freedom which includes a large
faction of people they're basically
saying leave me alone although else yeah
that doesn't sound like you can have a
peaceful divorce i mean you've got a
husband and a wife and the wife's saying
i want to leave and the husband's like
don't you dare or else i mean you need
more than just a court order you're
going to need police intervention and
protections
so
maybe you know when you see people like
ron perlman when you see like john
podesta and donna brazile in that 2020
scenario they did with the boston globe
reported on where they advocated western
state secede from the union if donald
trump wins the election again
maybe they will be willing to say fine
we're out right i will i will tell you
what i love the most about this trope is
the the the urban the city urban liberal
types are convinced that they will
flourish and the red states and
republicans will suffer and i'm like
do you know how to uh take care of
chickens for instance where do you get
your food from oh your avocados from
mexico were shipped in to your win in
the middle of winter and you're having
strawberries and avocado your strawberry
yogurt with your avocados yeah okay if
you don't know how to grow your own food
if you don't know how to and it's not
even about growing your own food we
learned this lesson we planted you
probably understand this we planted all
the tomatoes at once and that's a big
mistake
you plant them one week at a time so
that they the tomatoes ripen not all at
once otherwise you're eating 50 tomatoes
all at once we didn't know that because
we're a bunch of city folks who moved
out to the middle of nowhere
but the people who live in these cities
they get their food shipped in they do
jobs like writing at buzzfeed or working
for you know bureaucratic firms or
administrative firms or managerial firms
they're not the ones that for the most
part are making the machine churn
so in the event there was a major
divorce i don't think city i think
cities are gonna just implode they're
gonna go nuts yeah well tim what you're
not factoring in is that all of those
blue states have the reddit moderators
who walk dogs for 25 hours a week and i
don't know that we could stand to lose
them in all seriousness
in all seriousness one of the the issues
in this isn't just a problem with
national divorce or the the union
remaining together or whatever the
alternative is here
it's just an issue of the full like the
philosophical differences between left
and right here at least as they exist
today it's not so much that right
leaning people are all saying
i want to mind my own business i want
you to mind your own business there's
certainly that faction on the right but
even the right leaning people who would
like to see stronger government action
tend to be much more in favor of local
solutions whereas with left-wing people
they feel this unquenchable desire to
change things unbelievably far away from
them that they have no business meddling
in while problems fester all over their
own community and part of it is because
i believe that those external problems
are much more abstract and these are
people who aren't really interested in
engaging with reality and it feels
really good to say i'm going to effect
change and make the world better without
actually doing anything in your own
local community and so they end up
voting for policies that will affect the
way other people live their lives
without making any personal sacrifices
of their own
and so whether we have a national
divorce whether the country stays
together that tendency is not going to
change with those people i've got
another potential solution the national
divorce as a solution to like the
corruption the revolving door of people
coming out people getting bribed maybe
we can set up a direct republic right
now i've for a long time i've been
thinking i thought i don't think we need
the house of representatives you talked
to mike revell and he wanted to set up
what's called the national initiative
the idea that every american citizen has
the right to write laws and pass it into
the senate and we would all create our
own representative from our state so we
have 50 representatives of the national
initiative we in his world we still have
the house of representatives but i see
them getting bribed and they're
it's a vulnerability in the system what
if it was a smart contract and all of
the representatives these eight hundred
thousand people vote for the way they
want their contract to act while it's in
service and as long as it's there it's
just voting yay or nay as the populist
directs it i find the notion of going to
more of i know you call it a republic
but more of a democratic type solution
terrifying well i would call it a direct
republic it's actually less of a
democratic solution or it's equally
democratic let me let me uh be fair and
condemn my uh colleagues at the same
time
you know i don't blame aoc for what she
does i don't
95 of my colleagues i don't question
their motives or blame them for their
behavior even though it's wrong most of
the time i blame the people that voted
for them they're actually responding to
the people that elected them
that's that's even as you can say all
you want about the lobbyists and the
money and i have talked about how the
committees are messed up that way but
the individuals who get elected are are
fairly
reflective what bothers me is when they
say when you vote for me i'm going to
say yes to dog walkers and then they get
in they're like i'm going to vote no on
that and what recourse do i have now is
a voter i already this is what i chose
yeah well i think everything in the
house every two years you could throw
them out that is true we have to get
elected every two years
today's age two years is forever it's so
long but hold on hold on so so much when
you get now when you get a ron paul i
mean how many terms did he serve he
served a lot well if he was there for a
long time he served for a while and then
he came back
in like 96 because he he
he got
dis and he you know disillusioned didn't
think it was fixable but my
understanding is came back after he ran
for president my understanding is the
reason he won is because people really
like him
right is that is that true i don't live
in his district so was it that people
just vote republican it didn't matter it
was ron paul
the the reason most people win is people
like them
you nancy pelosi
they like her oh they love her san
francisco
they love her in san francisco you know
i'd like to think that people elect an
ideology or or but in reality they look
for people they like they do you it's
there's something to like about you know
i i i
marjorie i think you're correct we just
can't live with these people anymore if
they like nancy pelosi and find
something good in her i'm just lost i
don't i don't know i'm joining my maybe
you must find the love for all humans i
have a second thing
can i i can't understand that world if i
just can't i just want to throw one more
thing in here about national divorce i
sort of mentioned that even if we break
up the the federal government even if
all the states go their separate way one
group is still going to have a desire to
control and obviously they couldn't do
that the federal government at that
point but when you look at so much of
the actual censorship that the american
people are facing it's coming from large
corporations and that kind of thing is
always going to be weaponized i mean
national divorce or not it would depend
on your states and how they're set up
but here's something here's a second
thing that i think everyone should think
about while we're fighting out our
differences here in the united states
and among one another as americans the
biggest thing that upsets me is as
americans we aren't coming together as a
whole and saying we can put aside our
petty differences in our opinions what
we should be standing together on is we
should be standing against china we
should be standing against globalism
because if you want to talk about
authoritarianism and you want to talk
about people that really want to rule
over us
china is a direct threat to our entire
existence and let me tell you something
else china is embedded in the united
states there are politicians people that
thomas thomas and i work with that are
completely sold out i if you have not
read peter schweitzer's book the new
book that has come out i highly
encourage you to read it you would be
shocked there's a there's a whole whole
chapter on dianne feinstein that woman
has been there probably longer than all
of us have been alive
they have made so much money through
corporate connections um policy
deals that she was willing to make
through her powerful position as a
senator
with her husband stock deals
money investments i mean it is it is
outrageous that this actually happened
but it's not just them it's happened
over and over and over again
with people in power right here in our
country and this is the kind of thing
that i think we should come together on
republicans and democrats
yes both parties both parties sold all
parties there's more than two that's
when people say both i think they're
missing the mark because there are many
many political parties we talked about
this before the show you said congress
thomas you were telling me yeah it's
like set up for two-party literally
built with the fact that there's an
aisle forces you into two halves tell me
more about this you said there's coat
rooms there's a cloak room there are two
cloak rooms there aren't three i've
thought about this because i feel like a
trans partisan someday i don't know
which cloak room to go into but because
there's only two and they shoehorn you
know there's probably six or seven
kinds of parties that aren't named in
our country right now but then you
shoehorn them into two parties every
committee hearing room has two back
rooms you know you hear about back room
deals okay they literally call them back
rooms and there are exactly two back
rooms with every committee hearing room
they even have a smoking section
right yes smoking section yeah
like there's a democrat smoking section
or a republican smoking section in the
cloak rooms there's a smoking section oh
okay wow
but it's built into the it's built into
the architecture it would be really hard
and it's built into the rules like every
committee they say well we're going to
portion the committee based on the
majority and minority party the fact
that there's a a majority leader and a
minority leader and it should probably
cap it like we're going to set like each
party 10 parties and you want 20
committee members that means there can
be two from each party and then that'll
incentivize people to go to other
parties that don't have that many people
yet so they have a better chance of
getting on a committee i'm sure there's
a better way to do it i am absolutely
certain
well then what
what can we do
let me just elaborate a little bit i
mean you mentioned last time you were
here there's like what you say 10
democrats on one side 10 republicans and
there's some random guy reading going
like this bill says this democrats
republicans
democrats get it bang like that happens
yes oh yeah
that just says every day congress is is
is is is is broken it's theater theater
so what do we do to fix that that
well we've asked for recorded votes all
year um so for this this past year in
2021 i believe there's been over 490
bills that we've requested recorded
votes that's that hasn't happened in a
very long time in congress
this this is amazing and this is what
inspires me uh it gives me hope going
forward you're looking for some kind of
hope marjorie taylor green gives me hope
like on march 27 2020 i was the only
person asking for a recorded vote on the
biggest spending bill in history it was
verboten to do that it was not
acceptable and then marjorie came and
just made it the normal course that yeah
we're going to vote on everything she
didn't have committee so she sat on the
floor there were you know if there were
going to be three people in there there
was going to be one more and it was
marjorie
and she just started asking for recorded
votes but there are a dozen other people
who will take turns watching the floor
and asking for when you went in and
demanded that everybody come in and vote
how long did it take between when you
went in and when they all got there
real real quick i i i need to you guys
this is
you've set up a system now where among
the real people in congress we have a
schedule you make sure there's someone
there to demand everything we take turns
every single week where they're in
session we sign up for it and we i mean
we sit on the floor sometimes we're
texting each other no one's down there
or i have a meeting i can't go and we
work our way around and we make sure
here's what's disturbing it's amazing
it is amazing and it's inspiring because
it used to be me and i'm like i gotta go
to the bathroom
and i'm pretty sure and then i ended up
being in that position and oh it's
miserable and then they vote when you
walk out of the room yes oh my gosh yes
they do
they literally wait for you to leave in
fact
that may have been why on march 27th the
president called me
while the to get you out of the room
yeah to get me out of the room i'm not
sure if they had timed it that well but
i i stayed and let me calls go to
voicemail let me just
but but let me just say so that's
inspiring what that we've got shifts and
stuff but that's what your party
leadership's supposed to do
the the minority leader and the minority
whip they've got a dozen staff members
on the floor that know exactly what's
going to happen next they're working on
the script with nancy pelosi they know
which bills are coming and they should
be asking for the votes so let me tell
you funny story um motion to adjourn you
know i love motion to adjourn motion to
adjourn is something any member of
congress can step up and make a motion
to adjourn that that it calls for
everyone to have to vote to end congress
for the day and i believe often times
congress is so out of control i love to
make a motion to adjourn well recently i
came down to the house floor and i was
going to make a motion to adjourn and um
nancy pelosi found out because i told
one of the one of the floor staffers
that i was going to do it
so she came out and she opened the day
you know she started the whole day and
is and she looked at me directly and she
was talking faster than normal you tell
she was irritated and then you know what
she did she said the house will be in
recess
and she didn't let anyone do their
one-minute speeches and there were
several members that were really mad at
me because they didn't get to do their
one minute speeches because they knew it
was because i was going to do a motion
to adjourn
wow but they do they they talk
i want to let you know that after the
first time you came on
i had people messaging me friends and
family saying when i heard
that congress doesn't actually go and
vote and marjorie said she started
demanding it and forcing them to do
their jobs
people were like that was the moment i
realized she was great and she was
amazing and i loved her
i didn't i didn't know i mean you come
here and tell me that uh this stuff
about how they
they're basically just not doing their
jobs you tell us this stuff you talk
about how they'll wait for you to leave
the room before voting
i don't think regular people realize how
broken the whole system really is or or
more specifically you say they don't
enforce the masking until in areas where
there's no cameras it's all for show i
think when you tell people that
congress's approval rating is so far in
the gutter
that they're willing to believe it and
then when you mention oh yeah and we're
rotating shifts to make sure they all
have to do their jobs i'm sure people
started laughing their asses off when
they heard that well it let's not say
who the member is can we agree if i tell
the story yes
okay so marjorie had asked for a
recorded vote and and people were going
to miss some fundraisers and they were
really mad and this was a and i saw
people one at a time coming up to
marjory and just saying stuff to her and
so i'm
things so i went and sat next to her and
and one of our colleagues sat next to
her as well scott perry great guy great
guy
thinking that they wouldn't have the
audacity to come up and and yell at a
woman for actually just doing her job
well an individual did and i'm not going
to name him and and he started
mansplaining to marjorie
he literally standing over me he said i
know you're trying really hard to do
this job
and i know you care a lot but you need
to be thoughtful about this
and after about uh 60 seconds that i
couldn't take it anymore and i said you
know what
if your constituents could see you if
they could hear you right now they would
be so upset with you
you gotta say who it is no no no and
then he turned because we gotta be
friends so he turned his ire to me
and said you you worry about your own
district i know what my constituents
want
and i'll take care of my votes and you
take care of yours and you mind your own
business and i said you know what if you
if you're that certain that your
constituents are happy with what you're
saying go down to the microphone say it
in front of the camera let them hear it
i'm still shocked that it's not live
streamed all that action with little mic
lapels so that we can just watch you
guys actually it's not like you're
puppets but i mean we literally what a
reality
oh i'd give anything for a reality show
but i want to tell you something
thomas massey was the first person to
stand up for me and that was the first
time it happened the rest of the time i
had been berated and taking so much
anger and horrible things from other
republicans
that were mad at me for for asking for
recorded votes because they were going
to be on record they're cowards but
thomas massey stood up for and you want
to know why
he talked he's talked about he he went
and was forcing everyone to come back to
washington when on the biggest spending
but been the biggest spending bill in
this pandemic that in our nation's
history and he was saying our
constitution is still intact this is so
important we have to vote on this and
you wouldn't have believed what he had
to go through i mean
i love president trump but he he had to
deal with the phone calls and the tweets
and everyone mad and angry at him and
then he had his colleagues mad and angry
at him and everyone called him non-stop
trying to talk him out of it and he
still stood firm and he stood firm and
he made sure our constitution stayed
intact and this is such an incredible
story i truly think it's an important
part of our history that thomas massey
did that during this uh coveted 19 bio
weapon i'll say that i think it's that
and we have to prove it but but during
this what was happening to our country
we had one member of congress willing to
make sure that our constitution stood
in this in this historic time i'll be
honest i think i i was even critical i
think at the time my reaction was like
now is not the time for grandstanding
when we're being shut down and we're in
desperate need of aid and relief
and
we all make mistakes i think you know
now i look back at the mass spending and
the disaster that it's been by the way
there's they roll out contingency
government plans when things stop
working when the three branches quit
functioning they've got a contingency
plan and it is not pretty direct to 51
right no no no
not area 50 no no no no no presidential
directive 51. not familiar with that but
that was uh it's been updated but george
w bush signed into uh an executive order
called national security presidential
directive 51 which unilaterally grants
the executive branch the right
in any disaster to reform the government
under one branch under the executive
branch where they would have a national
continuity coordinator who would control
the other branches effectively and their
justification is a mass casualty event
anywhere in the world a financial
disaster anywhere in the world
it's been updated since then and
expanded but it's never been tested
because it's an executive decree so
we'd see we'll see how that could ever
play out if it could i want to mention
something you just uh said that you
believe that covet is a bio up and it's
interesting because according to dr
francis boyle who drafted the american
implementation of the national or i'm
sorry of the international bioweapons
convention
any disease or virus created through
gain of function research is a de facto
bioweapon it doesn't have to have been
made with the intent necessarily being a
bio weapon the reason this is
so easy to get fuzzy on and why they can
deny that it is one is because
they can argue well yes we used gain of
function research
to create this virus but we were only
making it because if someone else made
the same virus we would want to have it
first so we could know how to cure it
but that's like saying well my gun isn't
a weapon because the reason i have it is
just to study it take it apart clean it
i don't plan on using it well whether
you plan on using it or not it is still
a weapon and if these were if this was
created through gain of function
research it's a biological weapon
whether they claim that was the purpose
or not and that is again according to
the man who literally authored the
legislation on what a biological weapon
is i agree my analogy extending on that
is
they were playing with matches and the
house caught on fire yes and they said
well we were playing with matches so we
would know how to put a house exactly
they weren't matches but guess what they
ran they didn't they did not try to put
the house out they ran away and denied
they were playing with matches yeah yeah
exactly well and then denied that they
were matches in the first place this
wasn't a bat came in and lit this place
on fire well look look when you when you
get jon stewart coming out and making
those accusations on stephen colbert's
show this is not a fringe idea this is
something the american people believe
but let's go to super chats for those
that haven't smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends and make sure you go
to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members only segment coming
up at about 11 p.m over at timcast.com
you're not going to want to miss that
but let's read some super chats we'll
start with this one i'm going to try and
find i'm going to try and keep it to
questions for um
thomas and marjorie we have this one
from random eskimo he says please ask
marjorie taylor green what she thinks
about stacey abrams saying people
complained about her because it was
black history month i've seen racism in
my life but whining is not a solution
crack pipes matter
all right then
but not on the taxpayer's dime
no what i have to say to stacey abrams
is hiding behind black history reading
month is racist i think that's a racist
claim no what she had to do what she was
doing sitting on the floor um sitting
there
as a high risk person uh with covid19
and heard obesity
unmasked while children are being forced
to wear masks and they are not at high
risk that has nothing to do with black
history month that has everything to do
with being
an authoritarian elite candidate for
governor that i hope to god we defeat
and never allow to become and become our
governor who's running against
beautifully said who's you know who's
running against her well we're we're
having the primaries right now she has
no one being chat no one's challenging
her but we have governor uh brian kemp
is a republican in the primary david
perdue is a republican in the primary
vernon jones just dropped out and moved
to uh the 10th congressional district in
georgia and then there's one uh
remaining candidate candace taylor is is
also in the republican primary all right
we have this from matthew hammond he
says could we end baseline budgeting if
republicans retake the house what what
is baseline budgeting
it's it's saying that we're
we're only we're going to start with the
budget we had last year and we're only
going to add to it
um
what we need to end here's the biggest
change we could do
quit passing omnibus bills where when we
make all of the spun spending in one
bill
for instance here's what they do the pay
raise for the soldier
is always in the omnibus bill
so they threaten you especially if
you're in a republican primary you go
back home and you explain why you didn't
vote for this pay raise for these
soldiers well guess what else was in
there everything gain of function
funding is in there
well well well how do how do i i saw
that i saw that video of like the
they're they're carding in the 5 000
pages of the omnibus bill
who gets to add stuff to it
how does how does how does stuff get in
there can you guys add stuff it's
already written you know
if we tried to change one penny let's
say the total of it was a certain number
it's impossible to change a penny
because the agreement has already been
made between parties that aren't voting
on it and if we were to actually change
it they'd have to go back in that room
with the secret folks
and
well our leadership doesn't want it to
change they want thing they don't want
the government to shut down they want
don't want to get blamed for that here's
what's going to happen next congress
when we take the majority it's going to
be our omnibus bill now
and i would like to explain why it
shouldn't be an omnibus bill but it's
going to be our omnibus bill and they're
going to go to all the freshmen who've
never been in the majority i hope
they're listening to your podcast
and they're going to say look
this is bigger than you this is bigger
than us we we need to get a president
who can sign our bills so we don't need
any drama don't try to defund anything
in this let's get to 2024.
let's use what we got in 2022 to get to
2024. let's have hearings that make
biden look bad so that we can get our
president elected and you just vote for
the omnibus no drama there and and it
will be our whip team who is whipping
republican members to vote for an
omnibus what we should do instead
we should vote on the 12 separate bills
the the bill that funds the military
should be voted on separately from the
bill that funds the department of
justice through appropriations through
12 separate appropriations bills in fact
i would vote on 400 different bills
frankly i would totally agree and i'll
roll call every single one of them and
that way if you leave if one of them
would have had gain of function in it
and you left it out yeah and then you
don't get into
this grudge match with the president
where the government shuts down the
president doesn't have anything to sign
that has it in there you don't even give
him that option to fund those things you
don't want you give him separate bills
it's like the reverse of a line-item
veto who's making so much sense who's
going to be the speaker of the house
when republicans take the majority well
we only have one person running or that
we know is running which is kevin
mccarthy
so
there's but there's no one else running
so we'd you know can i tell you i was i
was a i i was a part of three coups
against john boehner architected the
second two coups one with jim breinstein
and one with mark meadows the third one
worked our third coup against boehner
the saddest day ever of my life in
congress is when the freedom caucus
agreed to vote for paul ryan
i was uh the second time paul ryan was
elected i was the only republican who
would not vote for him what would happen
if
the only republican every single
republican marjorie that you serve with
voted for paul ryan if they were there
when paul ryan yeah you were well so
inspired
when uh
after i think it's january 3rd right
everybody comes in and you have the
orientation so then you're going to vote
on the speaker and it's going to be
nancy pelosi and kevin mccarthy right
well no so our body is a majority
controlled body the body of congress is
so whichever party is the majority
control that that's the party that will
be choosing the speaker well no no no no
no unless they defect it but i mean
supposedly we'll be running you can you
can introduce other candidates right
there live time on the floor to the
clerk before there's a speaker in fact
we were the first people to do it
uh in the second coup against boehner we
introduced three alternate candidates
after both parties introduced theirs but
we think it may have been the first time
since
the country was was founded that that
actually happened i'm just i'm wondering
uh
so you're in the majority you're going
to win but you know now nancy well let's
say the republicans win the majority
kevin mccarthy there will be a vote
people will be voting for nancy pelosi
she's just going to leave oh yeah right
right so but what would happen if you
guys told the republican establishment
if you if you choose kevin mccarthy we
will not vote in favor of them
hands down no negotiating done what
would happen if you didn't vote for him
oh
speaker no no she would not so you have
to get a majority of those present and
voting so let's say the freedom caucus
peeled off let's say we had a majority
of 15 15 more republicans and democrats
and 20 republicans refused to vote for
the conference selection of that the gop
had selected let's say it was kevin
there would be there would have to be
another vote there would be a second
vote and then if those 20 again
disagreed to do it the probably the
republicans would go back into behind
closed doors the conference and and pick
somebody that could get a majority on
the floor that sounds like a great by
the way
i'm explaining this i'm not advocating
for it i'm telling you i've i led three
or lead two coups against boehner co-led
was a was a willing but
stupid participant in the first coup
never voted for paul ryan but here's
what i think the problem is we were that
was too simple of a solution the
definition the job definition of speaker
needs to change it's not about who you
choose a speaker and a hundred years ago
they changed they were successful in
devolving power from the speaker this is
what needs to happen the speaker
shouldn't be telling the chairman which
bills to bring forward the chairman
should be bringing the bills from their
committees to the speaker and say this
came out of our committee
the and and then that's how it should
work and i think we should i think
individual members of congress should be
able to bring bills to the floor and ask
for a vote i don't think it should be
completely controlled we certainly used
to be able to do that before you got
there with amendments we could on the
appropriations bill any member of
congress could walk up to the floor with
their amendment and get a vote on it it
should be back to that it because right
now we can like if i have a bill i
cannot get it to the floor for a vote
unless i have 218 members of congress
sign
to for for it to be voted on in person
or you know you know i'll in person i
just want we got to read more but i do
want to add i hope that uh when it comes
to the omnibus bill y'all just slip in
abolishing the nfa and the atf and it's
like wow it's in there you got to do it
but let's read this we got uh sharkbite
biz says marjorie why don't you sue big
tech for their bands as illegal
undisclosed election donations they are
it promotes and gives free publicity
marketing reach to your competition
during an election this is a clear
campaign donation
also check out our show sharkbite biz on
youtube oh sharkbite biz you're very
smart well i haven't said that i'm not
going to sue them so thank you for
bringing that up
so yeah twitter twitter is not out of
the woods
all right
okay let's see
josh says have either of you heard about
madison cawthorne's new term limits bill
thoughts on it thanks for all both of
you do for our nation
i i know about it i just learned about
it this week i don't know the details on
it um i've already signed the term
limits pledge
but i'm not going to term limit myself
unless there was an actual law passed i
don't want to see what i consider to be
the good guys leave on their own when
the bad guys are definitely not going to
leave and have no intention to do so
right that's that's always the big issue
because whenever i talk about term
limits i'm like didn't we all like ron
paul being in for as long as he was in
um you know exactly so
i mean i i don't know his particular
bill i've taken the pledge i sponsored
the term limit bills i'd vote for them
um if we could get them to the floor
but i think it's like a it's like a
cotton candy solution i call them it
tastes good but there's nothing of
that's going to stay with you
it might give you a sugar high people
they raise a lot of money they push this
issue they be a lot better off spending
their time trying to fix the broken
process in congress because even and
here's a question i ask um okay who
voted for us bozos okay somebody voted
for us and we're there so replace all of
us bozos who gets to pick the next set
of bozos the same set that picked these
bozos
well there you go all right
mohave says yesterday tim poole claimed
that generation x is politically weak
some of my fellow gen xers include
marjorie taylor green alex jones joe
rogan tucker carlson and ron desantis
when i said that i don't mean that every
single gen xer is incapable of doing
politics i said that when like by
politically weak you look at millennials
they won't shut up they're screaming at
the top of their lungs banging on the
walls making demands and they're getting
a lot of it gen xers are like most of
them removed and chilling and not really
involved well we were left at home a lot
as kids i think it was a latch launch
because we didn't have the internet when
we were growing up so like a lot of gen
xers don't really understand it like
alex or cortez she's like dude does
twitter and gets like 30 million
whatever because she's like young
millennial knows the internet so well
and knows how to work the algorithm and
so it looks like people that aren't
twitter probably boost her whereas
somebody like me twitter's like
yeah i also think it's sort of a truism
that the the rebels are always on the
college campuses the the revolutionaries
and um the old people vote
and maybe gen xers maybe we're just
between the college revolutionaries and
the old people who vote and maybe it's
just our phase of life i hope a lot of
those truckers are gen xers i i
gosh i love truckers right now all right
here's a here's one from gabe he says
who can small businesses go to about
demanding that esg scores not become a
norm if this is not possible how can we
make sure the esg rating agencies give a
fair score
are y'all familiar with the esgs what is
it environmental social good social uh
environmental social
governance governance thank you i don't
think we should have any of those i'm
not a climate change person
it's even worse than that yes i don't
think yes at crt so i don't think there
should be a scoring system
uh and everything's set up to hurt small
businesses right if you're a big
corporation it is oh gosh everything
goes your way but if you're a small
business if you're the little guy you're
fighting so many things and so many
regulations and so many different taxes
and you're a small shop you're a small
operation you might be a mom and pop
store or a single mom just trying to run
your little business and you don't have
the big
accounting department you don't have the
attorneys over here to help you with all
these issues and then when you come to
an esg issue it's just completely it's
it's another whole level that makes it
impossible to compete and these are the
type of regulations and ridiculous
things we have to stop and repeal
and and make sure that we allow small
businesses to be able to compete fairly
with the larger corporations this
shouldn't exist for a big company or a
small company but right almost all
regulations are scale prejudicial
they are harder for the small guys to
comply with whether it's food
regulations or or esg regulations
financials you said almost what are some
that aren't right off the top of your
head you have it i can't i don't have
any stuff in my hands you can build like
logarithmic i'm just protecting myself
against the fact checkers all right let
me
here's
vote yes on the trump impeachment twice
and if so why no i did i did not vote on
trump impeachment you didn't vote or you
voted no i voted no you voted against it
yeah yeah i i i was curious about that
that question but there you go what they
um what they might be recalling and i
shouldn't maybe advertise my unpopular
ass votes or aspects but
um i voted to certify the election
oh right right right and um yeah i'm not
i'm not a proponent of the fraud theory
or anything like that well and marjorie
we're on different sides of this
but here's my concern
you know the constitution pretty clearly
says that the state legislatures decide
and so i said before we got to the vote
many weeks before i said if a state
legislature tells me that their
authority was usurped
by
their governor or their secretary of
state or the judiciary branch if if a
majority of either branch of their state
government says that
then i can't certify their electors but
if they won't tell me that their
authority was usurped
then maybe they wanted it to be done
that way and maybe they would have voted
it that way i can't read it's like this
if you leave ten dollars on the table
and somebody picks it up and walks off
with it and you're okay with it did they
steal it this is something important
people need to understand uh not to
derail too much but uh just the issues
we've been having legally there are a
lot of people that want us to cut cut
slack on you know people who have
let's just say violet or security but we
we literally can't we we you know we
spot we we had a guy who trespassed i'll
just i'll just get into it with a guy
who trespassed and uh we talked to the
cops and the cop well he didn't trespass
he it's burglary so we have no
trespassing sign the moment he crossed
the sign he was officially committing a
crime because there's two actually it's
a big driveway it's a it's very very
large like a thousand feet and then he
came up to the house and entered the
building which officially becomes fourth
degree burglary
we we talked to the cop and the cops
said if you don't enforce this you lose
standing in the future to enforce
similar actions like it be it becomes a
weaker position for you because they'll
say you're selective geez it's like the
system set up to make you become an
authoritarian i think you want to run a
business no i i think it's reasonable
listen if you claim that you don't allow
strangers to come to your property but
then some of them you do a judge is
going to look at you and be like oh dude
what's the reason for your selective and
i feel like people get into power and
then they're like i don't want to do it
but i'm going to send troops into the
war like i don't want to do it but i'm
going to do the violence so not to
derail
but just that you know
by the way the other concern while i'm
talking about that is if we get in the
habit of congress overriding whatever
the the election system produced then
now we've nationalized elections and
states like kentucky don't fare well
when
uh when you do things that way
well i just think the the strategy needs
to be
you know right now ground game for
republicans i think republicans need to
be resisting the voting changes i think
the democrats are trying to push
push
their uh voter overhaul bill and that is
the electoral college act that's what
well
well no the the they call it the voting
rights bill
manipulation that's the democrats bill
yeah what republicans need to understand
and i think i feel like this is lost on
so many people the reason universal mail
in voting is so advantageous to
democrats is because democrats live in
dense urban populations where two
activists can hit a thousand doors in a
day whereas for republicans in more
rural areas you're driving miles from
each house that's right so
look a democrat activist knocks on a
door hey see that thing on the ground
fill it out right now just do it i'll
wait okay go to the next door do it
republicans got to drive dude in the
cities you can go down to the lobby and
throw it in the outgoing mailbox exactly
exactly it's ridiculously easy for
democrats to vote that way so
i think
voting should not be blindly easy and
anybody who argues voting should be
super easy no it shouldn't no you
shouldn't have to show an id it should
be an act that you take on yourself you
willingly go to cash your vote and it
has you have to have proof of
identification that you're a citizen
proof of your address it has to be very
secure but the other thing about
objecting i objected on january 6 and i
would do it again and the reason why i
believe it was so important to do it is
because there were thousands of people
that signed their name at risk of
perjuring themselves in a court of law
saying that they had witnessed voter
fraud and those affidavits i i believed
were very important and as a
representative and elected
representative of the people in my
district i felt like i needed to
represent what they were saying and
there at that time were not able to
prove what they were saying in court and
so i did object to to key states but you
know that's the great thing about like
thomas and i we may not have done the
same thing on january 6 and he didn't do
anything wrong and he has always
supported president trump and and
definitely
actually probably supported trump in
many ways that people
didn't support president trump i think
that's one of the things that a lot of
people don't understand um but as far as
objecting i just i think our election
system is we it is so valuable and we
have to make sure that it's always
protected do you know the moment that it
was certain all 50 states would do
mail-in ballots
was on march 27 2020 when congress said
it's too dangerous for us to show up and
vote so we're going to do all this by
remote control
and and republicans agreed except for me
marjorie wasn't there yet and and i said
no you've got to show up and vote well
you had the president and a majority of
republicans in congress arguing it was
too dangerous for congressmen who have
good health care and security it was too
dangerous for them to actually show up
and vote so then how do you then make
the argument that everybody else should
show up and vote it's pretty hard to get
that high ground all right let's read
some more we got a couple here
zimmeru says marjorie my mom thinks
you're racist because you said something
bad about kwanzaa i'm black and i don't
care about kwanzaa either but can you
say something to convince her you aren't
racist or hate black people
i i don't know how you're supposed to do
it i don't either it's it's definitely
that accusation is not true of me and
all my friends and family that know me
personally would never say that about me
um just because i said that that kwanzad
i called it a fake holiday i don't think
it's something that should be promoted
and and you know i mean they can promote
it anyone can celebrate anything that's
the great freedom we have in our country
and and for people that care about it
but the founder of kwanzaa is someone
that actually murdered two women
and this is this was a a very radical
extremist the man that founded kwanzaa
um i think people should understand the
person behind kwanzaa and and the person
that started this movement um and it's
not at all what is talked about today in
those terms so when i had talked about
kwanzaa it was um
you know i'm not impressed with a
holiday that started by someone with
such radical beliefs uh but it has
nothing to do with anyone's skin color i
i don't like identity politics i don't
engage in it i could care less um that's
not something that matters to me the
creator was maulana karenga and i
believe was created in california yes
all right we got one from lance he says
tim if you're okay with citizens owning
all forms of arms how do you keep people
from turning the country into an actual
war zone what punishments do you put in
place for those who use these weapons on
each other well the same uh you know
we've had a very hard time stopping
american citizens from shooting each
other in mass warfare
no we haven't people have guns they walk
around west virginia all the time
there's people who walk around with
ar-15s there's people who walk around
with guns on every part of their body
they can carry a gun on you know the
funny thing about the left's argument on
gun control i'm sorry i'm sorry i always
got to correct myself
the democratic establishment because
leftists true leftists love guns true
just not as soon as they seize power
then they want to take your guns away
but for the establishment players who
want to ban guns
you know
how do you stop people from running over
running over other people why is why do
they never discuss well how would you
stop someone from getting in their car
and running people over it's like well
sometimes it happens it's it's
horrifying and that we arrested them and
we put them in jail and intentionally
remember the parade everyone wants to
forget about the christmas parade of
course oh that's right
never happened
my point is heartbreaking my point is
not that cars are intentional weapons my
point is that people drive around
multi-ton objects all day every day and
i'm not worried about them ramming into
each other and having destruction
derbies and parking lots or anything
like that and when you actually live in
a state where everybody's armed all the
time
do you you you never ask yourself well
gee i was walking around in west
virginia nobody was shooting anybody
else why why is that it's because people
don't want to
so look i think you know there are
people luke
luke grakowski of weir change sends me
this uh gun broker ad and it's for a
hand crank nine millimeter gatling gun
and he's like you gotta buy this
people owned these things no one is
carrying those things aren't going dude
like it just doesn't happen we also have
several examples in the last several
years where that's not happened every
state where they have passed
constitutional carry and by the way that
means you can carry a firearm without
out asking the government's permission
without going through training without
getting a photo id paying taxes every
state the prediction has been it'll be
the wild west you're trying to turn west
virginia into the wild west you're
trying to turn kentucky into the wild
west it's never happened it doesn't go
that way people don't just start
spontaneously shooting each other when
you allow people to carry fire what
happens to the crime rates they go down
exactly and right now we have record
high crime and that's why that's why
owning a gun is so important that's why
constitutional carry is so important
that's why georgia needs to pass it and
if we don't get it past people gun
owners are going to be so angry in
georgia if we don't get constitutional
carry because we're at the threat of
losing a republican governor and having
stacey abrams who literally in her
announcement speech
that's what she talked about reducing
gun rights taking away guns that was in
her announcement margaret i i cannot
believe you would say that about her
during black history month that's so
horrible oh i forgot that
before we go to the member segment we
have uh beastly who says question for
marjorie
you say have a national divorce and we
need to stand against china how is that
possible with a weaker america suffering
from ccp subversion well i talked about
the national divorce as one
option that hopefully we don't have to
do but we may end up having to be there
because democrats and their
authoritarian
policies and controls may force us to
that point but i said we also need to
look towards each other and put aside
our differences and realize that china
is our real enemy what i was getting is
that it was where you do you mean the
ccp
ccp i think of the chinese people i feel
like they're enslaved
under the boot not the people the
government the ccp yeah not directed at
the regular zero zero zero zero one
percent of that population or something
yeah a very powerful less evil
organization
controlling the chinese people so i
would like let's
we'll talk about some here's what we're
going to do
we're going to go start recording our
uncensored members only segment and i
want to talk about the cdc and i want to
talk about the election things that
youtube makes it very difficult to have
honest conversations about unfortunately
that's the reality and we try our best
to make sure those conversations can
still get out so we're gonna have those
conversations so go to timcast.com
become a member uh help support the show
smashing those smash the like button
subscribe we're gonna have that episode
that member segment up around 11 or so
p.m so you don't want to miss it at
timcast.com you can follow me at tim
cast and you can follow the show at tim
cast irl we're on instagram with clips
uh thomas do you want to shout out
anything social media or your website
follow sassy with massey
ss
s-a-s-s-y m-a-s-s-i-e
that's my hashtag if you're looking for
me on twitter are you guys fundraising
by chance for a re-election absolutely i
only take uh i'm supported mostly by
small dollar donations i don't take any
money from big corporate interest or big
packs
so
mtg4america.com and if anybody wants to
pitch in five dollars 25 50 bucks i'm so
grateful that's what keeps me going and
that's what helps me fight back against
everyone that's trying to take me down
mtg4america.com by the way you're
smarter than me i didn't mention the
website that would
allow you to donate
thomasmasi.com
will you could go there and donate to me
i was number 438 in fundraising out of
435 congress wow
this is what i won because he doesn't
call and beg for money all the time
the non-voting delegates of guam and
puerto rico raised more money than me
in in a six-month period oh my gosh they
don't even get to vote wow and so
anyways i'm not the best fundraiser i'm
still upright is what i want to know i
think it's going to tip over because
your member from georgia was concerned
about that yeah
anyways uh thank you very much
uh i am seamus coghlan i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we upload
political satire and political cartoons
every single week sometimes twice a week
we have one coming out tomorrow about
the feds that i think you all will enjoy
when you're doing that youtube one that
so that's gonna be for behind the
paywall because everything we say in
that so we're working on a pay wall
right now basically we're gonna put some
exclusive cartoons up it won't take away
from the weekly uploads we'll still be
putting out just as much content but
there will also be extra stuff uh and
tim and i recorded this very funny
fouchy bit which will never ever be
allowed on youtube
it would
yeah yeah exactly exactly dude you guys
had so much i don't want
i learned a lot tonight yeah this is
really great i hope you guys come back
and tell us more because i have a lot
more questions and i feel like we at
least nailed like a third of like the
stuff i would i would have loved to have
talked about tonight oh i'll come back
let's do it
i'll be back and keep
pumping these websites
uh rand paul next time yes yeah it's
great and dan crenshaw i'd love to have
a debate i think it'd be wrong i would
enjoy a debate yeah yeah dan's
see i'm one of those i believe in the
the civil war and the gop i think we
need to work it out iron sharpens iron
and we need to work to be the republican
party that supports our base and
represents our base i'm ian crossland
follow me in crossland.net i'll see you
later i hope you guys all enjoyed this
as much as i did i enjoyed it a lot just
sitting here and listening and learning
i am sarah patchwood on twitter and
minds.com we will see all of you over at
timcast.com
sign up become a member help support our
work we'll be up around 11 or so p.m and
we'll see you then bye guys
you